nineteen years into an era of superhero
franchises there's a term I've been
hearing used more often to describe a
film a classic I find this phenomenon
interesting for a number of reasons for
one it's proof of how widely accepted
superhero movies have come as a John
rrah
but it also poses an interesting
question of what exactly makes a
superhero movie a classic several films
come to mind most notably Christopher
Nolan's at the Dark Knight Jon Favreau's
entry to Iron Man and more recently
James Mangold's Logan but if there's one
film that perhaps deserves the title
better than anyone I wouldn't hesitate
to say
how do you adapt a character as iconic
as spider-man this was the question of a
bewildered Hollywood for nearly 25 years
during which the film was initially
stuck in development too many people
surprised the man who is eventually
hired to rescue the project was this man
Sam Raimi a director primarily known for
his low-budget horror cult classics like
The Evil Dead and dark man his
background being the reason for the
overt horror undertone throughout his
adaptation of spider-man Sam Raimi's
answered to the decade-long dilemma was
quite simple he didn't make a film about
spider-man
instead Raimi chose to make a movie
about the man behind the mask Peter
Parker as a comic spider-man has always
been a story about Peter Parker as much
as it was a story about spider-man in
fact it was one of the first comics ever
to put as much emphasis on a superheros
alter-ego but it was also what made him
such a beloved character because he was
relatable Spiderman showed that
superheroes can worry about their rent
lose their jobs or have relationship
problems this was an appeal that Sam
Raimi clearly understood and in truth we
often forget most superhero movies are
all essentially character adaptations
and more often than not whether the
filmmaker has accurately captured the
essence of the character determines the
success of these films and I think it
was this reason that allowed Sam Raimi
to make a series of what are now
considered the modern classics of all
superhero movies oh right and spider-man
3 we'll get to that in a second the
scene that perhaps best exemplifies
Raimi's understanding of the character
is also its most famous one Peter
these are the years when a man changes
into the man he's going to become the
rest of his life
just be careful eh engines with great
power comes great responsibility it's no
exaggeration to say that this very scene
is one of the most iconic scenes in the
history of the genre and it does make
you wonder why and it's because of this
simple line with great power comes great
responsibility
that Raimi uses to encapsulate the
entirety of his franchise whereas the
first spider-man dealt with the theme of
great power its sequel deals with the
concept of great responsibility each
telling quite a different story that
once put together creates a coherent
message there are many ways Raimi
achieves this the most obvious being the
use of his villains spider-man is
essentially a film of contrasts between
two characters Peter Parker and his
eventual nemesis Norman Osborn
accentuating their similarities I'll
make a few calls
no I couldn't accept it sir I like to
earn what I get I can find my own work I
respect that as well as their
differences you and I are not so
different
Wow to each his own both our characters
who are suddenly gifted a power that
they hadn't expected but just like the
words of Uncle Ben
for the attendant it's what they do with
these powers that change their outcome
Rainey spends a good first half of the
film focusing on Peters confusion on
what exactly his power is meant for what
do you see coming from you
I don't know
[Music]
whatever it is something I never felt
before
and at first his choices are often
questionable like how he decides to use
his power for a new car to impress the
girl he likes tragically it's also this
selfishness that ultimately costs the
life of his uncle at that exact moment
were shown Norman Osborn also find
himself at the brink of losing what he
loved but you can't do this to me you
know how much I sacrificed when faced
with loss the two characters make a very
different choice Peter after the words
of his uncle chooses responsibility and
Norman chooses the opposite and when the
two finally face one another their
confrontation I'll be at physical is
really a clash of their ideals on how
they choose to use their given power and
if spider-man was a movie about power
its sequel is a film about
responsibility and more specifically the
burden of it Peter spends most of his
time in the film dealing with the
consequences of his choice in the first
one his responsibility as spider-man
loses him his job the girl he loves and
even his best friend the reality of
living the life of responsibility
finally hits him what I need
what am I supposed to do once again met
with me choice Peter chooses to abandon
the responsibility no Uncle Ben
I'm just Peter Parker
I'm spider-man
and rainy again uses its villain Otto
Octavius to accentuate this struggle he
also being a man obsessed about his work
whose feeling of responsibility to do
the right thing intelligence is not a
privilege it's a gift and you use it for
the good of mankind ultimately leading
him to his tragedy and what eventually
turns both of these men back to their
original role is a reminder from those
that they love and respect on the
necessity of doing the right thing you
once spoke to me about intelligence that
it was a gift to be used for the good of
mankind no matter at the cost to do
what's right we have to be steady and
give up the thing we want the most even
our dreams and it's this moment of
self-discovery
when Peter Parker finally becomes
spider-man and also coincidentally the
moment of that MJ finds who he had been
all along it's a moment that seems right
out of complex hi
this is perhaps the reason why
spider-man 3 could never have been a
good movie by the end of its second film
the story that Raimi had been trying to
tell was completed the story of how
Peter Parker confronted his power and
learned the importance of responsibility
to become the hero we know what remained
after were just heavy handed drama and
pointless villains milked for the sake
of continuing a valuable franchise what
Sam Raimi achieved with the first two
spider-man was game-changing it taught
future filmmakers of the genre the
importance in understanding a character
before adapting one ironically also the
reason that would come to break and
revive the same franchise when given an
immense power to adapt such an iconic
and beloved character with a history he
understood better than anyone that with
great power comes great responsibility
and that alone is why spider-man
deserves to be a classic